this episode was made possible by
generous supporters on patreon
hey crazies figuring out what's going on
with quantum particles can be a real
hassle sometimes mainly because their
behavior works against us you've
probably heard of the infamous double
slit experiment because everyone and
their mother has done a video on it but
most of those videos are designed to
mystify you
let's bring quantum mechanics back to
reality whenever you're trying to learn
something about quantum mechanics never
forget the following maxim quantum
mechanics is not magic there are real
physical things happening here that are
independent of human existence we just
need to figure out what they are the
double slit experiment is a good place
to start it's an example of something we
call a whichway experiment where all we
want to do is figure out which way
something went if we know it started
here and it ended here did it take this
path or that one or some other weird
path honestly it's a pretty common
question to ask about anything physical
being able to make predictions is kind
of a big deal adding in barriers is a
perfect way to narrow down the options
and focus our attention as we move
forward in this video we're gonna ask
progressively deeper questions about
this experiment about what its results
actually mean we're going to add pieces
to it as we go until it looks like this
the delayed choice quantum eraser that's
where we'll find the deeper answers but
we have to work up to it slowly so
settle in in a previous video we did the
double slit experiment with a full beam
of light if you're not familiar with
that experiment or how wave interference
works you should go watch this video
first and come back after okay let's
keep going we want to take the double
slit experiment into the quantum realm
and know it doesn't look like this at
all in fact it doesn't really look like
anything because light doesn't work the
same way on that level down there light
is made of individual photons
what's a photon the smallest piece of
energy in a beam of light we've spent a
lot of time modeling light as a wave in
the electromagnetic field but that's not
always the best model especially for a
laser like this if we make it really dim
the beam stops being continuous
we start to see individual packets of
energy called photons if we make that
beam dim enough it'll release one photon
at a time then we can send each one into
the double slit experiment every time a
photon hits the screen it records the
interaction as a dot at first everything
looks fine individual photons are making
individual dots after a while you'll
notice a pattern build up on the screen
it's an interference pattern the first
thing that result tells us is that the
photon is a wave wait isn't the photon a
particle yes but but not in the way
you're probably thinking when you hear
the word particle you probably think of
something like dust it gives you the
impression that quantum particles like
photons are little balls but they're not
quantum particles are just localized
waves at all times
their behavior is described by a wave
function which is a solution to a wave
equation they are always waves
a pattern like this and the double slit
experiment tells us there is
interference and a wave is the only
thing that can interfere like that just
to be clear though while the
interference pattern tells you the thing
is a wave the non interference pattern
does not tell you the opposite this
pattern does not mean particle it just
means we're inconclusive about waviness
so photons are waves but they're tiny
nacelle ins of location and that's gonna
be very important as we try to
understand their behavior in general
this isn't a waviness test or a particle
test
it's a whichway test the point is to
test which way something went did it go
through slit a slit B or both slits
simultaneously that's the second thing
our photon result from earlier can tell
us the only way this interference
pattern is possible is if each
individual photon went through both
slits simultaneously seriously both
slits how is that possible well if each
photon is actually a wave then this
isn't all that surprising but what if we
tried to detect which slit each photon
pass through sure we could do that but
then we'd get a different result
polarisers do a pretty good job of
separating photons just after slit eh
we'll put a horizontal polarizer and
just after slit B we'll put a vertical
polarizer that way we'll be able to know
which photon came from which slit
unfortunately now the pattern looks like
this instead no interference doesn't
that mean that light is a particle dude
keep up we just went over this
while the interference pattern tells you
the thing is away the non interference
pattern does not tell you the opposite
this pattern does not mean particle it
just means we're inconclusive about
waviness but it doesn't matter if we're
inconclusive this time the previous
experiment already told us that photons
were waves this new result tells us
something else entirely
it tells us the detection of each photon
change their behavior now each photon
only goes through one slit or the other
not both the photons knew we were
watching no that's not how this works
that's not how any of this works
remember quantum mechanics is not magic
I never said anyone knew which slit each
photon went through I only said they
were able to know each photon interacted
with the polarizers that interaction is
what changed the behavior of the photons
not the person it made the slit
information available whether or not a
person actually took advantage of that
availability is completely irrelevant
the humans are not important so then
what's actually happening probability is
happening all of the photons come out of
the same hole in the laser each photon
could exit from anywhere along its
diameter but they're more likely to come
out of the center than the edge so the
photons quantum wave looks like this
the height of that wave gives us some
idea of where we might find the photon
at any given moment
eventually that wave encounters
something like our slit wall most of the
photons localized on the barrier and are
destroyed but some of them localized on
the openings and pass through each
photon wave that passes through has both
slits available to it they're either
detected by the wall and localized in
one area or they pass through both
openings that turns the slits into two
independent sources of probability that
can interfere
each other the new wave looks something
like this on the opposite side of the
slits it spreads out as it travels until
the photon localizes on the screen it
gets destroyed its energy is transferred
and we see a dot those dots still have
size because it's impossible to localize
a particle to a single point you know
the uncertainty principle and all that
jazz over time those dots build up on
the screen and eventually form a pattern
since each photon localizes randomly
based on this interference wave that
pattern on the screen is an interference
pattern so what about when we did all
that detecting there's an extra
interaction the polarisers force each
photon to take a particular polarization
since each slit has a different
polarizer each photon can only pass
through one of them the new wave looks
like this on the opposite side of the
polarisers and that remaining wave peak
travels to the screen and gives us a dot
but that's a different probability wave
arriving at the screen which means we
build up a different pattern over time
the extra interaction with the
polarizers prevented the interference
quantum mechanics is not magic but what
about the delayed choice quantum eraser
ok fine it's time for that anyway but
just so you know the same rules apply
the best way to test any hypothesis is
to try and prove it wrong is there any
way we can delay the detection until
after the photon hits the screen yes but
we need to be a little more creative the
photon that hits the screen is
immediately destroyed upon impact so the
first thing we need to do is copy the
photon if we put a special kind of
crystal immediately after the slits
every photon will be split into an
entangled pair of photons each photon
having half the energy of the original a
for that we need to split up the
partners a special kind of prism should
do the trick one partner goes off to the
screen the other partner goes off to
some detectors detector a is for slit a
and detector B is for slit beef by
separating the two partners we can make
the detection happen whenever we want we
could do it immediately and it would be
just like the previous experiment with
the polarisers but if we do it way later
the upper photon will hit the screen and
make it
before we detect the slit information
what kind of pattern do we get then just
like before if we detect the photons we
get no interference for real it doesn't
matter when the detection is made all
that seems to matter is that the
information will become available hmm
let's take this up a notch if we add in
a beam splitter before each of our
detectors only half of our photons end
up getting detected the other half
passed through and we can send them
somewhere else why would we want to do
that to erase the information we can
send that half of the photons into a box
called the quantum eraser if a photon is
detected by that box we have no idea
which slit it came from the information
has effectively been erased from
existence this means we're only
collecting slit information from half of
the photons in this case the pattern on
the screen looks like a big mess but
don't forget we're still only sending in
one photon at a time which should let us
keep a record of which hits are
entangled pairs when we use that
information to separate the dots on the
screen we get interference for the
erased half and no interference for the
detected half by performing all these
detection x' and erasers much later it
almost seems like a photon gets detected
and is like oh crap I'm detected then it
somehow communicates that to its
entangled partner in the past so it'll
land without interference get ahold of
yourself Nick quantum mechanics is not
magic okay reality check that last
experiment is what we call the delayed
choice quantum eraser and it's rather
elaborate and convoluted if we jump to
too many conclusions about that kind of
result
we'll have to subscribe to a particular
interpretation of quantum mechanics
there's a whole bunch of these
interpretations some have been ruled out
but some pretty crazy ones still remain
let's not go down that rabbit hole today
how about a more rational perspective we
spent so much time focusing on the
delayed detectors over here that we
didn't stop to consider the screen is
also a detection you could just as
easily say the pattern in the wall is
what determines what happens at the
other detectors
whichever detection happens first
determines the other detection I mean
the pattern can't even be seen
until all the detection czar made anyway
quantum mechanics is a physical model
that allows us to make predictions about
really tiny things maybe that's all it
is
maybe elaborate experiments like the
delayed choice quantum eraser just
expose the limits of our physical models
in quantum mechanics maybe the rational
perspective is the craziest so do you
feel any better about quantum mechanics
let us know in the comments thanks for
liking and sharing this video don't
forget to subscribe if you'd like to
keep up with us a special thanks goes
out to patreon patrons like Matthew
O'Connor
oh and O'Sullivan and I'm Korg business
meek who help make this show possible
with their incredibly generous support
and until next time remember it's okay
to be a little crazy doesn't the
photoelectric effect prove the photon is
a particle nope the photoelectric effect
is a special case of the energy
conservation principle the photon is a
discrete packet of energy that discrete
packet just happens to be a wave thanks
for watching
[Music]